左边是原视频,右边是AI生成的视频
为什么我们视频复刻效果这么好
因为我们现在用AI做视频
再也不是普通的提示词生视频的逻辑了
而是Image 2故事版加Saydowns 2.0
直出视频形式
你重点看三个地方
我们的视频人物有没有乱变
产品有没有跑偏
镜头节奏是不是基本都对上了
以前AI生视频最难的地方可不是让画面动起来
而是人、产品、动作、镜头、节奏
是不是全都对得上
很多AI视频为什么看起来非常的假
就是因为前后不关联
你的人脸会变
产品会变形
镜头也不听话
但这道方法非常的不一样
所以为什么说Image 2加Saydowns 2.0故事版生视频
这道方法非常值得大家去做
因为它基本上一次性解决了
AI生视频最麻烦的五个问题
第一就是解决视频前后关联的问题
第二解决1比1复刻长视频的问题
第三解决人物和产品一致性的问题
第四解决反复抽卡的问题
第五可以和智能体工作流结合
把AI生视频的生产效率最大化
简单点来说
以前我们AI生视频逻辑是写一堆提示词让AI自由发挥
现在是把人或场动作运进节奏
全部都锁进一张故事版里
然后再让C2.0照着故事版去生的视频
所以说它不是让AI去乱创作
而是让AI按导演分镜一样去执行
接下来我直接猜给你看一条爆款视频
怎么从拆解换素材生成故事版到最后做成一条能发的高质量的AI视频
首先第一步先找一条你想复刻对标视频
注意我们不需要抄它的内容而是拆它的结构
它前三秒怎么抓人中间怎么展示产品镜头怎么切
人物怎么动最后怎么收尾
你要复刻的是镜头语言
内容节奏和成交结构
可不是直接搬运别人的素材
第二步让AI拆这条视频
你可以把对标视频或者关键截图丢给AI
让它反推出四个东西
第一口播脚本
第二分镜画面
第三运进节奏
第四每个镜头的画面提示词
这一步非常重要
很多人做AI视频一上来就生成
这就是为什么非常容易翻车
因为AI根本不知道你要节奏是什么
正确的顺序一定是先拆爆款
再替换成自己想要的内容
第三步
你要准备好自己的素材
也可以叫替换素材
因为异品复刻不是把别人的视频搬过来
而是先明确知道视频里到底要替换什么
是换人物还是换场景
还是换产品还是换服装
你要先把替换目标想清楚
再建立自己的素材资产库
所以你至少要准备三类素材
第一产品素材
比如产品的白体图
产品的细节图
产品的使用场景图
第二人物素材库
比如人物的正面图
侧面图
表情图
动作图
第三是场景的素材
比如说室内的场景
街景
店铺
货架
周面
办公室
如果说你要做服装类
还要单独准备服装素材
服装白体图
模特上身图
面料细节图
不同角度图
这边有个细节
就是你的素材一定要干净
产品图越清楚
你的产品生成视频越不容易变形
人物图越稳定
人脸和动作越不容易紊乱
场景图越明确
后面的视频的真实感就越强
因为Seda 2.0最后生成的视频质量
很大程度取得于你前面给它参考的信息质量
你前面的素材越像一个完整的资产库
后面AI生成视频就越像一个完整的项目
而不止一条临时拼接出来的AI视频
第四步
也是最关键的一步
用Image 2生成故事版
这一步是整个流程的核心
你不要只让它生成一张好看的图
你要让它生成一张视频制作的故事版
故事版里必须包含每一镜的画面构图
人物动作产品位置
场景变化
光线氛围镜头眼睛运进方向
甚至每一段的时间节奏
简单来说
故事版可不是海报
故事版是给AI看的导演说明书
以前我们写题词是把信息写在文字里
现在我们是把信息压进一张图里
这就是它真正厉害的地方
那第五步就是把故事版交给Seda 2.0
这里很多人会犯一个错误
就是故事版已经把信息写得很清楚了
你就不要再写一堆复杂的题词
你会污染AI去识别你故事版的信息的
你只需要前面三件事情
保持主体质
保持镜头节奏
保持产品和人物不要变形
如果是产品视频
就强调产品的外观稳定
如果是出镜的真人视频
就强调人物一致
动作自然
镜头真实
Seda 2.0强的地方
是它对多么太参考的理解比较好
它可以读图
读视频
读文字
所以你给它参考信息越完整
它执行的越稳定
这也是为什么
Image 2
故事版加Seda 2.0
会变成最近非常火的组合
第六步
后期对齐原视频节奏
如果你要做的视频是1比1复刻
那你后期一定要做三件事情
第一
保留原视频的镜头节奏
第二
用自己的产品和人物替换原素材
第三
把AI生成的镜头
重新卡到原来的节奏点上
这一步决定
它像不像一条
真正能发的高质量的视频
很多的AI视频
为什么最后做出来看起来讲
不是因为模型不行
而是因为后期没有节奏
镜头切了伞
动作接不上
音乐卡不上
观众一眼就会觉得
是Error很浓
所以最终的完整流程
不是AI生成视频
而是对标视频拆解
替换自己的素材
生成故事版
然后C2.0生成视频
后期对齐节奏
最后剪辑成片
我对我再总结一下
普通人做AI视频的逻辑是
我写题词
让AI自由发挥
故事版工作留的逻辑是
我先把视频拆成导演风景
再让AI照着执行
前者靠运气
后者靠控制
这就是为什么
它适合做电商视频
短剧片段
人物展示
产品展示
甚至AI博主自己的
技术演示视频
都可以由故事版去做
但这里我要提醒大家一句
不要直接扳别人素材
不要拿没有授权的人脸
品牌和影视IP去复刻
真正安全的做法是
复刻结构替换素材
用自己的产品
自己的人物
自己的场景
去复刻爆款的视频逻辑
这才是普通人真正能长期
用好AI生成视频
去做好的方法
好
Image2故事版
加C2.0直出视频的方法
已经给大家讲完了
那接上一条视频
就是大家现在看到的这条视频
也是AI让我出的
因为我告诉他
我要做一个AI博主
他跟我说
那你第二条视频
就绝对不能再讲概念了
让我拿出一条
能真正证明我
AI技术判断的内容
所以他让我讲
现在大家用的
比较好的
生成AI视频的方法
而且一定是最新的
所以大家看到这条
我讲Image2故事版
加C2.0直出视频的视频
就是我给AI教的第二份作业